that is the game I believe that
companies have the opportunity to take
themselves from a non human element to a
human element I believe and this is
about to get real weird so stick with me
for a half a sec I believe that we're
living through the beginning of the
humanization of logos that we are going
to have relationship with logos I equate
it very similar to what's happened with
the pet dog if you look at the data of
the pet dog in the 1950s spot spent most
of his time outside now spots inside but
I think as many of you know spots pretty
aggressive he actually doesn't only live
inside he lives in your bedroom and I
don't know about this but you might know
spot actually wears better clothes than
you do and he wears better clothes and
he eats better than you do because he
eats gourmet every single night you'd
only are kids into your bedroom and spot
sleeps on your bed that is what has
happened with the data we have humanized
spot once they're done humanizing our
circle we humanize our pet and if you
start looking lipton brisk I see is one
of our clients during the NBA Draft this
year we had one of the highest
engagements around the NBA Draft with
Lipton brisk because people were asking
hey at Lipton at brisk what do you think
about that pick in the second round
truly tweeting our logo like that our
boy truly humanizing why because when we
engage on Facebook and Twitter and these
platforms who are not just using it as a
press release so many of the companies
in here when I was doing my little
search are using their Facebook pages as
another newsletter